in context and the context the really
important step was her majesty's
incredibly successful visit to the
republic of ireland
remember before that happened uh the
republican movement were positioning
themselves to oppose the visit hoping
that they would gain in popularity in
the south base doing so and then they
discovered
that the queen's visit was enormously
popular with the people in the republic
and they quickly changed their position
and this is yet a further example of the
extent of which they have changed their
position
i mean that was the what i really want
to ask you because in terms of
those people who want to united ireland
and people such as yourself
who want to preserve the union what does
this tell us that it's kind of business
as usual polite relations between the
leading republican party and the
representative of the crowd yeah it just
shows us the the republican movement
that originally was genuinely republican
and wanted to disrupt the united kingdom
is moving further and further away from
that and closer and closer to some
degree of normality but they're not
really reach normality full normality
until they're in a position to actually
face their past
and face it for what it was or other
dirty nasty terrorist campaign but does
this mean that you know a united ireland
is kind of off the agenda for now
oh yes but it was never all that
seriously on the agenda
and even with what has happened in
scotland it's not i think coming back on
the agenda i mean there was always a
question of uh
as i understand it if there were
referendums on both sides of the border
then it could happen oh yes in theory
that is the position uh but there's been
no effort by uh the republicans to uh to
suggest there'd be a referendum i'm
quite obviously for that because they
can see themselves how little support
there would be even amongst nationalists
i mean i mean that said shin fein and
jerry adams in particular
in the south in the irish republic are
gaining quite a lot of support they're
becoming a very significant political
force aren't they
well they did have a
a degree of support coming to them when
they were opposing the european union
austerity programs now that the
republican has come out of the program
the position is changing and the opinion
poll earlier this evening
showed the uh
jerry's position dropping three points
pianofoil coming on on par with them but
significantly finigale moving six point
seven points ahead of of shin fin now so
i think we're going to see that the
little surge of support they had which
related to the circumstances of the eu
bailout isn't going to apply now that
ireland has moved out of that and is
recovering economically and do you
believe
in spite of what you say about wanting
them to reconcile with what they did in
the past
that the shadow of the government if i
can put it like that is now removed from
politics in the island of ireland
generally speaking yes there are still a
few wrinkles in the situation due to
what we call dissident republicans
but while there are
a number of people there with the
capacity uh to do harm they have no
significant popular support and that's
the really crucial thing and people like
jerry adams and martin mcguinness and
jerry kelly who were associated with the
parliamentary era have genuinely moved
on and then given up violence in your
view yes that's that's
one's assessment of it but it would be
better to hear it more clearly and more
unequivocally and indeed what they
should be doing at this stage is is
telling dissident republicans
that they you know they understand where
they were because they had been in that
position themselves but they realized
that the terrorist campaign was never
going to succeed and was the wrong thing
to do if they could address distant
republicans in those clear unequivocal
terms that would do a lot to bring an
end to that
how difficult do you think
this must have been for prince charles
bear in mind his closeness to his uncle
lord matt martin
well
obviously he decided to do it
and if he decided to do it i i don't
think it helps for us to try and
speculate as to what was in his mind
when he was when he made that decision
i'm sure it would have been a difficult
decision for him to make but he has
decided to do it and well done
i i mean what i was really relating to i
mean you too and almost anyone in
northern has been personally involved or
personally affected by the violence
people you've known very well being
killed does that make it more difficult
or less difficult to seek reconciliation
to shake hands well
yes i know i understand
that aspect of it and all of us in the
early stages of the talks and all the
rest
find it initially extremely difficult to
be dealing with people who had been
engaged in violence but i think
it
we all want to see the situation improve
we all want to see people be able to
move on it'll be easier to achieve that
if those who had been engaged in
violence can be frank about
what they did and equally frank about
putting all of that behind them i don't
think we should be left with any
ambiguity
on a lighter note what do you make of
the gay cake ruling as it's been called
in northern ireland
well
yes
suspicion that both parties were being
rather silly but there you are
are you pleased that you can now order a
cake it's full of gay marriage
well yes but does that mean you could
have on top of the cake anything else
that might be regarded as provocative by
other people but i don't know i think
really it's uh you know okay
i can understand people feeling uh
having mixed feelings about
equal equal marriage
but the laws moved there and the things
time for us all to move on
every term